So, we're interested in exploring the situation where a determinant, b squared
minus 4ac, is negative or less than 0. The reason this is an issue is because we
know we need to take the square root of the determinant, and right now, we have
no idea what taking the square root of a negative number means. None of the
types of numbers we've dealt with so far can express the answer to this
equation. So, I guess that means we're going to need a new kind of number. Let's
look back then at all the kinds of numbers we have dealt with. Here's a diagram
depicting our world of numbers that Julie introduced in the very first lesson of
the course. I know this looks a little bit different because I decided to use
rectangles this time instead of circles, but all the sets and subsets have the
same relationship to one another. You can see that we have the natural numbers,
which are inside of the whole numbers, which are inside of the integers, which
are inside of the rationals. And together, the rationals and the irrational
numbers make up the real numbers. The question I have for you then is where this
new kind of number we're talking about belongs. We see that the number n is some
negative real number. Where should we put the square root of n? Does it belong
in the natural numbers? The whole numbers? The integers? The rationals? The
irrational numbers? Or outside of the real numbers?